tennislegende boris becker in london
nicht wir wollten nicht centre court
sondern vor gericht
im insolvenzverfahren solle
vermögenswerte verschwiegen haben dass
kann ihn teuer zu stehen kommen bis zu
sieben jahre haft drohen die richterin
ist gnadenlos überlegte fußfessel und
hohe kaution wegen fluchtgefahr
immerhin musste er seinen pass abgeben
die nächste anhörung ist ende oktober
becker selbst beteuert seine unschuld in
allen neun zehn anklagepunkten da ist
wieder eine menge los trau mich dass er
kaum zu sagen an schraube der arme mann
gefiel mir so ein
das will ich jetzt durchaus richtig ja
weil ich denke mir wenn eine über 50 ist
der heißt nicht becker herr becker
sondern der heißt der boris ja wie die
über 50 jahren dass darüber muss man mal
nachdenken
angelo oder der christian stadt
christian dennis kelly durch seine frau
dr merkel das ist der boris ja dem wird
immer irgendwie in unserem bewusstsein
ein heranwachsender sein also er tut mir
leid obwohl er zu mir nie sehr nett war
ja hat einmal zu seiner damaligen frau
waage sagt barbara überlegte mit wem du
befreundet bist direkte die eliminiert
ich da rede ich mit dem verleger und
dann ist die frau weg ja also ich war
nicht weg er hat ihnen das erzählt hat
dass barbara direkt ja ja das haben wir
von mehreren seiten gehört aber später
ich bin mir oft sehr oft begegnet und
einer weise wird er immer wird er immer
ein idol sein ja der mann der junge mann
der wimbledon gewonnen hat der typ der
immer kämpft und selbst wenn man denkt
dieses tennis spiel ist vorbei
dann steht noch einmal auf und kämpft
das finde ich wirklich bemerkenswert und
den wird für millionen menschen würde
ein idol sein ja und ich habe auch auf
twitter und auf den in den sozialen
medien gelesen wie viele sagen lasst
doch den armen mann in ruhe auf der
anderen seite das was er gemacht hat ist
kriminell er hat einfach einen großteil
von von nicht großteil also einige
immobilien gelder hat er wahrscheinlich
irgendwo noch versäumt und
wahrscheinlich ist das wichtig geworden
wahrscheinlich
eigentlich hat er ja ein bisschen was
versäumt und sagt das habe ich irgendwie
vergessen ja aber er würde ja nicht vor
gericht stehen wenn die haben die dinge
ja gefunden ja und er sagt nun ja das
werde ich irgendwie so erklären und ich
glaube sein naturell ist oder so sagt
ich bin der boris becker ich komme da
raus auf alle fälle und im übrigen
glaube ich auch dass er irgendwie raus
kommt er mir auch überhaupt nicht leid
finger er bildet das eigene
selbstbewusstsein auf die füße gefallen
und ich finde das sieht man auch zum
beispiel daran dass er nichts besseres
zu tun hatte als bei dem ersten
gerichtstermin danach in scott in
mayfair erst mal essen gehen oder fahren
der angebliche heute ist und aber nur
insolvenzverfahren wirklich
schwierigkeiten hat setzt sich danach
erstmal hin und sagt so jetzt gibt es
aber erst mal hier bei mir war ja noch
nie den feinfühligen dass er gewisse ist
morgen der ist selbstbewusst wie donald
trump leute was wollt ihr von mir ich
bin der boris becker ich weiß wie es
geht wenn er übrigens moderiert und und
tennisspieler erklärt das macht der
fantastischer und und er ist hat also
als persönlichkeit eine totale präsenz
ja und wenn der innenraum reinkommt dann
ist der raum voll das muss ich wirklich
sagen obwohl ich nicht seine freundin
benya also deswegen tut mir ein bisschen
leid weil ich glaube dass irgendein teil
eine lebenserfahrung fehlt dem wir alle
anderen hatten wir haben irgendwie
gearbeitet die wir uns ein partie ja dem
hund ist doch gar nicht so schlecht aber
oder empathie oder das gefühl man muss
sich anpassen man muss sich an regeln
halten
es gibt regeln die für uns alle gelten
ja aber ich glaube boris becker ist der
meinung der steht weit drüber das ja ich
sage aber auch neben dem motto
debattieren im netz ist natürlich wenig
gemeinsam ja und wie diskutiert mal mit
einem nativen am besten gar nichts mit
lang mit ihm genau das will ich noch mal
darauf zurückgehen gute frage ich habe
nicht mitleid mit ihm was
da angeblich gemacht haben irgendwas
muss er da dran sein das ist natürlich
durch europäer das land oder heinz
müller von nebenan das macht man nicht
es gibt gesetze und die analyse hat man
sich zu halten
aber was ich so hart findet wie das
jetzt obwohl es nicht fix ist er so
dermaßen gehetzt wird und gejagt wird
und das laufende also ich glaube dass
wir schwer raus also der ja auch der
braucht scheinwerfer und ich meine das
mag ja das ist hier hat das sind ja ja
ja ohne scheinwerfer ich bin weil ich
gesehen werde
ja man darf auch nicht vergessen der
boris becker war der mann der gesagt hat
als seine tochter auf die welt kommt das
samenraub ich meine kann man sich dass
das meine ich da ist aus denken ja aber
aber wie gesagt das hat er gerne aber
dann kann er ihnen doch auch nicht
leitung mit oder im übrigen kein
bisschen leider doch gelang es ihm tut
er mir leid warum also es geht ihm
blenden er hat offenbar nehme ich mal an
noch genug geld das ein wunderbares
leben in london führen kann ja ist
ärgerlich großen eventuell ein paar
fehler gemacht die werden jetzt
verhandeln die treffen ihn aber nicht so
wahnsinnig im kern dass sie sich da
offenbar wahnsinnig große sorgen darüber
macht aber ich hab das gefühl boris
becker meckert die ganze zeit über die
wahrnehmung über die wahrnehmung wir von
außen wahrgenommen wird ich muss nach
london ziehen die deutschen erkennen
mich nicht mehr genug an jan valentin an
nein ich glaube dass ich glaube auch
nimmt daher kommt in den knast nein es
ist ich glaube das wird sich noch jahre
solvenz verfahren ist irrsinnig
kompliziert da gibt sicherlich noch so
ein paar türen ich will auch da einfach
keine bewertung machen was er da und wie
es heißt er hat kunden verschwiegen
es geht um 15 millionen also das sind
schon entsteht und die wohnung aber
irgendein scheich irgend ein bewunderer
von ihnen und er hat noch viele und er
sagt okay was kostet da ist ja dafür
musst du dann halt meinen kindern
tennisunterricht geben oder nach sonst
wohin ziehen da gewann anja hörnich leid
tun also woher haben wir natürlich schon
sein empfiehlt einfach eine erfahrung
eine lebensspanne die wir alle hatten
erst aber mitleid das ist also das ist
nicht so der arme wird gehetzt wird
charlotte signal sondern damit auch der
arme ist geht er fasst er in den bereich
der arme bobbele der hat aber einen
entscheidenden aspekt in seiner liga
verpasst habe ich schon mitleid mit
menschen denen du irgendwann einfach
lebensweisheiten lebensweisheit das
gefällt mir gut ja dass das fehlt ihm ja
und es würde auch die haben ja
[Musik]